fine unless you've been living under a
rock for the last number of weeks it
should come as no surprise that Frieza
was added to universe sevens squad for
the upcoming tournament to make up for
the fact that majin buu fell asleep
ignoring of course obvious character
bias and blatant shoehorning I have to
say that I'm grateful that resurrection
F wasn't our lasting image of Frieza and
so far his portrayal and execution has
been well perfect
however this last-minute substitution
has made my series incomplete and well
we can't have that now can we
so you guys know the drill using as much
official reference as I can muster
together I will try to find out what is
freezes current power level you know for
fun he's the most wicked he's the best
worst guy he's the closest thing Dragon
Ball will ever get to an Oscar he's
Frieza I'm torn up mark and this is the
power level series episode 8 Lord Frieza
[Music]
freezes race is undefined however we do
know that he's a hybrid mutant of said
race with an age of approximately 80
years standing with a height of 5 feet
and a weight of 100 pounds his
techniques include death beam death ball
death saucer and touch of death Frieza
has four officially stated power levels
those being five hundred and thirty
thousand over 1 million 60 million and
120 million however we have every
indication that freezer will be vastly
stronger than that today so let's have a
look unlike the other participants in
universe 7 squad Frieza doesn't have the
luxury of being a mainstay like Goku and
Vegeta are in the series no matter how
much they try in the beginning Frieza is
described in the series as this hugely
powerful intergalactic dictator who
oversees his own army
the Frieza force of which the Saiyans
the main series antagonist in the arc
prior were members and we all know how
that turned out
additionally friezes father king cold is
a mutant with an abnormally high power
level and due to this Frieza also
possesses those mutant traits making his
power output far greater than the norm
among freezes race and even greater than
his father cementing his place as the
strongest in the universe you know apart
from beerus release in majin buu but
let's ignore that for now Frieza might
not have been the first to introduce
transformations to the series but
certainly is synonymous with them the
funny thing is these really aren't
transformations or at least not in the
traditional sense everything before
quote his final form our states of
suppression forms he reverts to or
perhaps even created to better manage
his immense power in short the rest of
frieza's race would probably be walking
around like this because they don't need
to suppress anything in truth Frieza
only had one definite transformation but
I'm getting way ahead of myself here
let's start at the beginning we are
formally introduced to the character
Frieza while accompanied by zarba and
dodoria as they attempt to convince the
namekian people to hand over their
Dragon Balls good thing he overheard
that conversation between Knapp and
Vegeta otherwise this wouldn't have
happened at all once all of his forces
have failed to squash the efforts of
Goku Vegeta
Krillin and Gohan Frieza not only loses
his wish with the dragon but is also
forced to take
matters into his own hands for the very
first time we see him go face to face
with Vegeta who shockingly enough at the
time after having gone through a series
of enormous power boosts is on pretty
equal footing with Frieza
in his most suppressed form or base form
Frieza has an officially stated power
level of five hundred and thirty
thousand but Vegeta's equal footing with
Frieza wouldn't last too long why
because he has so many transformations
the first of which brings him over the 1
million mark in terms of power level he
also gains what looks like five feet in
height only to lose it all at once in
unveiling his true final state which I
still considered to this day as being
the best villain character design in the
series great job Akira Toriyama once we
cut to the meat and bones of this
confrontation with Frieza
who was fighting against series
protagonist Goku Frieza at this time
using only 50% of his power or utilizing
a power level of 60 million is making
sport of Goku literally bashing his face
in on the verge of fatigue having
exhausted all other techniques like the
Kamehameha and kaio-ken with a
multiplier of times 20 Goku bets
everything on the spirit bomb or
genki-dama depending on your translation
which amazingly Frieza survives though
not completely unscathed
what follows is something I'm sure
you're all familiar with Frieza kills
Crillon Goku doesn't much like the fact
the fries are killed Crillon Goku
screams the black off his hair goku
fights freeze as a blonde dude yada yada
yada it's covered extensively what's
important here is that Frieza during
this battle he utilizes 100% of his
power bringing our final officially
stated power level to that of 120
million okay so that was the easy part
now comes the hard part the part that
involves no officially stated power
levels after his defeat at the hands of
Goku we next see Frieza when he arrives
an earth in his newly mechanized body
his presence is fleeting however as a
new super saiyan called trunks proceeds
to slice and dice the mechanical purple
hitler and believe it or not that was
the last time we saw Frieza as part of
the main series story excluding
non-canon elements like movies and
filler the last time Frieza featured in
the manga was in 1991 and we wouldn't
see a Canon Frieza until a resurrection
F 24 years later
2015 in story however it's only been
about 15 years but still 15 years so
freezes story kicks off once again
thanks to the efforts of newly
introduced characters sorbet and Takuma
the former having taken up command and
freezes stead they decide to resurrect
him because reasons and that leads to
this which I am completely fine with
because it has this song and yeah you
bet I'm covering the events of the movie
why you ask because that show never
happened
hey no shut up it never happened
Frieza goes on to claim that if he were
to train an Ernest for four months he
could reach a power level of 1.3 million
which on the surface makes absolutely
zero sense unless you provide of course
the excuse that he was referring to his
base form which if that was the case why
would he do that seems like a
meaningless measure of power in my
opinion I however believe that people
read far too much into that part of the
conversation when in reality the most
eye-opening aspect of it came moments
prior when he said this never trained a
day in my life there was never a need
imagine what could happen if i unlock my
latent potential it is here that Frieza
states that he has no experience
training Frieza might know words like
salubrious and gauche but he can't know
something if he has no experience in
practicing it so because of that the 1.3
million remark is that most an extremely
rough estimate based on zero experience
fast foreign Frieza who was having
difficulty defending against Goku in
base form reveals that he has now
unlocked a new transformation one that
goes beyond his previously established
final forms of limits he dubbed it
golden Frieza Goku had been dominating
freezer prior to the transformation
without utilizing a transformation
himself suddenly Frieza flips the script
on Kaku in his golden form and stamina
aside he was stronger than Super Saiyan
blue Goku who was at the time the gangs
strongest character alongside Vegeta in
less than four months Frieza went from
losing to
in a previous episode of the powerlevel
series we have already previously
estimated beerus to be somewhere in the
region of 245 quintillion and you can
check out this video to find out why in
short I established an estimate based on
the context of the series between beerus
Goku and Vegeta so during the
resurrection F ark Goku might be
somewhere in the region of 4% beerus
bearing in mind that beerus is as strong
as the story demands
unlike the battle of gods movie which
touted that beerus used 70% of his power
whereas in the anime he stated that he
was beginning to think it was a waste of
time indicating that Goku was far below
that of beerus is power Akira Toriyama
has also been quoted and saying that
they have no plans for Goku and KO to
surpass beerus and Wiese he was of
course referring to the Dragon Ball
super anime so if you're interested in
seeing the mental gymnastics I had to
perform to come up with that figure I
will leave a link in the description
down below to the video that you want to
see but basically Goku falls somewhere
in the region of around 4% beerus at
this time which equates to roughly 9.8
quintillion so for the sake of balance
and ease of calculation we will guess to
make Frieza to be somewhere in the
region of 10 quintillion seeing as he
was a fraction stronger than Super
Saiyan blue Goku again this could be
lower or higher there are no official
statements or references for this
section of the story with regards
strength levels sadly or thank God
depending on your point of view Frieza
gets go Coonan isn't seen from again
well until
today
hey guys she mighty master okay I'm not
even gonna lie this that was amazing
initially when the news broke that majin
buu was going to be falling asleep
thus impeding his ability to participate
in the tournament of power my initial
reaction was however then it was
revealed that Frieza was going to be
taking his place suddenly I had bigger
problems I began to get flashes of that
thing I told you that didn't happen by
the way it didn't happen shut your dirty
mouth but what followed was was
sensational easily some of the very best
episodes I have ever seen in terms of
Dragon Ball superb animation great
character acting on point dialogue with
an interesting story twist my sucking of
Super Snake aside it also brought to my
attention something strange or at least
something I thought was strange up until
very recently Frieza during the period
of time between the resurrection F Mark
and the universe survival arc had grown
stronger and not just a little stronger
much much stronger accompanied with
proper key control so strong in fact
that he could brush off the key of the
universe 9 god of destruction yeah
freezes the man now recognized but it
got me thinking if Frieza has no
experience training or fighting and had
no means of moving even how could he
increase his power output so sharply
well your good friend toilet mark has
the answer as we have already
established Frieza is a prodigy a
naturally gifted warrior with potential
that went untapped because as he said
that was never a need however when he
was forced to train for the months
leading up to resurrection ex main
battle it's not outside the realms of
possibility to think that Frieza picked
up a few things so by the end he could
have known how to train and get stronger
quickly at that but I hear you ask he
was still in the cocoon thing unable to
move how could he possibly train well
with an established technique called
image training in the past we have seen
characters like piccolo focus on
meditation Vegeta has stood in
wastelands for days at a time
trunks did is in preparation for black
heck even Gohan and Goku used this
technique to see if Crillon was strong
enough in this very arc so having
established that Frieza would learn
quickly how to train it's not
farah reached to assume that he could
improve quickly through this methodology
especially when he was given nothing but
time taking all of that into account and
that he went head to head with full
power super saiyan blue goku yielding a
tide result this must mean that the now
redubbed true golden Frieza which is
free from inefficient stamina
consumption would be somewhere in the
region of fifteen quintillion or more
considering relative to Goku he is near
equal however there is still no concrete
evidence to suggest that both were going
all-out in this exchange we know that
Goku is capable of multiplying his
strength through the kaio-ken so who
knows what Frieza might be capable one
interesting point that I think is worth
mentioning
Goku states prior to freezes
resurrection that if he acts out both
himself and Vegeta would keep Frieza in
check however after fighting with him
Goku only mentions himself as being the
one to keep Frieza in check I could be
reading too much into this but this
could also be an indication that Frieza
at this point is the second strongest on
the team
pushing Vegeta below him keep an eye on
that space Frieza is and always has been
my favourite villain and I am thrilled
to see that he has made this much of an
impact so long after his initial
unveiling back in the early 90s there is
something to be said however about
finality and its importance I am firmly
in the corner that all great things must
come to an end Dragon Ball Z never
prepared for that and as a result had a
subpar ending as long as Dragon Ball
super has an ending in mind I am willing
to sit back and relax as Frieza
continued to do what he does best
being an intimidating ruthless merciless
conniving conspiring reckless selfish
manipulative bloodthirsty bastard all
words which describe the now more
powerful than ever
Frieza bow to the Emperor I hope you
guys enjoyed this bonus episode of the
power level series I've been totally nut
mark and as always thank you so much for
watching